so wait I love this about you because
I'm not good at taking photographs but
you're into photography and you're so
amazing at it oh thanks yeah you have a
great eye I got to see like some of your
work and I want to show everyone that
but how did you get into it I picked up
a camera
um do that and you just were amazing at
it like one of those old uh Polaroid
cameras you know the accordion ones and
they saw pack film yeah politically in
the 90s and I I wanted some instant
gratification and they gave these really
beautiful little black and white images
no negative and one-of-a-kind kind of
feelings yeah that's how it started I
love that I love a puller I I own like
three different kinds I love Polaroids
well okay here's here's one so this
photo can you tell us about this one oh
yeah I shot a film called uh The Quiet
American in Vietnam in 2001 and our the
story is that
um of an American who goes to uh Vietnam
bringing foreign policy and Aid and it's
a controversial film
um for its criticism of American foreign
policy blah blah blah but that meant
that we were the first production uh
Western production in Vietnam to shoot a
film
um forever and and that was to do that
one but that meant because it's a
communist country that the cops were
always following us around the place
yeah so we were infiltrated by Hanoi and
these were the cops and they were always
following us around so one day I just
went hey hi and I just locked up and
started taking pictures me making
friends with them making they're really
nice guys you know I know even though
like I love the photo that you took like
even the ones you could just see the
eyes in the back it's like each one has
a story that they're telling like with
their eyes I love it it's really cool
yeah nice shot nice eye I don't have
that I'm so jealous here's another
camera with you yeah it helps I bring
the camera Brendan and it doesn't go out
that way if you look really closely
that's Michael Kane and he was uh also
my well my scene partner in the film
also and that's a bunker there was a
scene we were getting shelled and it was
very muddy it dug out and Yeah to keep
myself from feeling like I was going
bonkers I started taking pictures of
stuff and so anyway that's Michael yeah
I think it's good to have something to
you know to do that's outside of your
job you know and and I I capturing
images is something that is important to
me yeah I quilt yeah good for you not
good at it but I loved it doesn't matter
I'm an amateur Enthusiast with the
camera anyways you know I think it's
awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
guys I'm going home
[Music]